[Musique]
j'aime pas trop
oh [ __ ] et des ossements par tous par
terre on est vraiment obligé de passer
par là
[Musique]
quoi
on est avec brut dans les anciennes
carrières souterraines de paris qui sont
plus connu sous le nom de catacombes
alors si vous êtes prêts à découvrir la
ville sous la ville c'est parti le sous
sol de paris c'est plusieurs milliers de
kilomètres de galeries qui contiennent
notamment les égouts le métro et les
catacombes
est ce qu'on appelle les catacombes en
réalité ce sont les anciennes carrières
souterraines de la ville dans lesquels
on est allé chercher la pierre pour
construire paris et à elles seules ces
catacombes constituent près de 300
kilomètres de galeries sme
alors parfois au détour d'une galerie on
peut tomber sur ce genre de plaques qui
nous indique en dessous de quelle rue on
se trouve donc c'est vraiment comme si
on était dans une version souterraine
parallèle est inversé de la ville
[Musique]
là on voit vraiment le conseil ça
c'était vraiment les carrières à
l'époque
donc on voit les la démarcation du
souchais ici j'ai beaucoup plus meuble
et qui permettait de détacher des
énormes blocs de pierres sales et ça on
pourrait le détacher facile si on
voulait ça c'est pas du tout la grosse
modification de l'alliance était
vraiment le mesf romain ok mais il reste
encore un sacré paquet au xviiie siècle
il y avait tellement de galeries sous
paris que la ville menacé de s'effondrer
alors on a créé l'inspection générale
des carrières pour consolider les sous
sols et la plaque que vous voyez ici
marque la toute première consolidation
qui datent de 1777 et le g que vous
voyez là c'est pour guillemot qui était
l'inspecteur général des carrières et
qui d'une certaine manière à sauver
paris de l'effondrement
[Musique]
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale on va
construire des bunkers dans les
catacombes et encore aujourd'hui on peut
en voir 3 il ya un bon coeur de la
collaboration un bunker de la résistance
et un bunker allemand dans lequel on se
trouve actuellement
donc on peut encore voir les
installations électriques on peut voir
deux vieilles portes blindées comme
celle là et on trouve encore des
inscriptions d'époque sur les murs
[Musique]
et
il
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
l'eau qu'on peut voir dans ces galeries
c'est pas du tout les égouts
en fait c'est une eau qui est très
propre et les seuls l'impureté qu'on
peut y voir c'est le calcaire qu'on
remue nous même en marchant avec la
voyez tous les petits escargots convoi
incrusté dans la roche
c'est des faux cils qui date de l'époque
où paris était sous la mer il ya environ
250 millions d'années
c'est dingue et consolidation la
[Musique]
première s'adresse à sa part de tous les
côtés thiam america vendredi et
révolutionnaire ici et on voit jusqu'au
dessus que ça c'était pour les ouvriers
en fait ils meurent écrivait juste au
dessus ce qui devait un graphe gaz est
d'accord
[Musique]
les oeuvres qu'on peut voir dans les
catacombes toutes les installations ça
constitue une culture à part entière
cette culture elle est entretenue par
une véritable communauté souterraine
qu'on appelle kadhafi
[Musique]
est ce que tu peux nous dire ce que
c'est que les kadhafi qui est comme son
nom l indique c est ce qui m legata donc
on peut venir y chercher de la
tranquillité mais on peut venir aussi
faire la fête il voir ses amis et
poussant mes fesses à créer une grande
communauté avec des gens très différents
mais mais tous reliés par ces mêmes
pressions des katas on est coupé du
monde extérieur on n'a pas de téléphone
on arrête d'être connecté en permanence
on est juste à l'instant présent avec
les personnes qui nous entourent à ce
moment là
[Musique]
[Rires]
avant internet les cataphiles se laisser
des messages sur papier qu'il cachait
dans les catacombes
mais aujourd'hui la tradition continue
on peut parfois trouver des tracts
[Musique]
donc en général il ya la tête à laquelle
le tract a été déposé le nom du kata
fils et là c'est des actualités
scientifiques et on peut voir que c'est
le numéro 34 sur 50 donc mais on a
encore 49 qui sont disséminés dans les
catacombes
[Musique]
c'est aux espèces d'agglomération
d'ossements qui ressemble un peu à un
nid de guêpes sont diane un peu espèce
de l'installation artistique là aussi
très macabre flippante plus tard on n'a
vraiment pas envie que ça nous tombe sur
la gueule au xviiie siècle les
cimetières de paris déborder
littéralement en particulier celui des
innocents qui était devenu un vrai
problème de salubrité publique
il y avait des odeurs cadavérique
insupportable pour la population
donc on a transféré les ossements dans
les catacombes en sous sol donc
aujourd'hui on peut voir comme ça des
ossements de milliers de parisiens qui
se sont retrouvés entassés ici dans
l'anonymat le plus total
les catacombes sont visités depuis des
siècles on y trouve des traces de toutes
les générations qui se sont succédé ici
par exemple on peut voir un dessin au
fusain qui date de la révolution de 1848
avec ici regardez nationale et devant
lui un insurgé
[Musique]
alors parfois en sortant d'un passage
très exigu on peut déboucher sur une
salle immense comme celle ci une des
salles les plus mythiques des catacombes
qu'on surnomme la plage à cause du sable
qu'on peut voir sur le sol alors les
catacombes
on l'a vu ça peut être considéré comme
un musée historique puisqu'il ya des
traces de toutes les époques sur les
murs mais c'est aussi un musée d'art
puisqu'on peut y trouver tout un tas de
création d des sculptures comme ce golem
donc qui soutient le plafond qu'on
appelle le ciel ici et c'est pas tout il
ya aussi énormément de fresques et de
peinture qui date de toutes les époques
et pour faire un petit récapitulatif
historique donc ce lieu au départ
c'était une carrière puis c'est devenu
la cave d'une brasserie
ensuite ça a été converti en abris de
défense passive et dans les années 70
donc on a recouvert le sol de sable pour
remblayer le sol pour remonter un petit
peu la hauteur dont je vous parlais de
peinture tout à l'heure la peinture la
fresque la plus célèbre de ce lieu plage
oblige cette superbe reproduction la
vague de hokusai
[Musique]
ici on peut voir une des fraises que les
plus spectaculaires des catacombes
c'est une adaptation du célèbre tableau
de moknine l'îlot mort et elle a été
peinte en une année par l'artiste
l'homme slovan alors à la base du
tableau on peut voir un talent drôme en
latin qui dit nous tournons en rond dans
la nuit et nous sommes consumés par le
feu
[Musique]
comme elle représente la face sombre et
cachée de la ville les catacombes ont
toujours suscité des tas de fantasmer au
tehrik et au 19e siècle par exemple il y
avait des charlatans qui faisaient
descendre les gens à la bonne société
dans les sous sols pour leur présenter
le diable arrivante une mise en scène on
sait tenir débout kerry le complice qui
faisait des bruits un petit peu flippant
c'est un spectacle son et lumière et ce
qui est intéressant c'est que encore
aujourd'hui on peut croiser le diable au
détour d'un mur
[Musique]
qu'on suit sous terre je me sens sereine
apaisée je me sens bien et pour moi
c'est aussi un nombre dans paris sous
paris qui est le plus grand en droit de
naturel de cette ville on a entouré de
pierre alors ça ressemble de tekna de la
nature pour pour tout le monde mais
messi en fait on a entouré de nature
brute ya pas d'animaux il n'y a pas de
plantes mais mais il n'y a pas d'endroit
plus naturel pour moi ce moment à paris
qu ici
alors je tiens à préciser que cette
vidéo a pour but de vous faire découvrir
le monde souterrain des catacombes mais
pas du tout de vous inviter à y
descendre d'abord parce que c'est
passible d'amendés et ensuite parce que
ça peut être très dangereux
personnellement je ne serai jamais
descendu si j'étais pas accompagnés par
une équipe de gens habitués et entraîné
donc si vous voulez découvrir le pari
souterrain je conseille plutôt de
visiter les catacombes officielle qui se
trouvent place denfert rochereau
[Musique]
il